my sincere apologies to his victims for
our failings he should not have been a
police officer
um that's very obvious
um a range of poor policy and poor
decision making he shouldn't have been a
police officer and we failed
and we haven't we haven't applied the
same sense of ruthlessness to guarding
our own integrity
that we routinely apply to confronting
criminals
and I'm deeply sorry for that
for one of carrick's victims the apology
isn't enough she's planning to sue the
Met
police were warned about carrick's
Behavior nine times before he was
arrested for rape I'm not the same
person I was before I met him during our
time together he made me feel scared
humiliated and worthless
I've carried all of those feelings with
me for years
the victim has consulted campaigning
lawyer Harriet Westridge we are
exploring potential legal remedies which
could include a claim for damages under
the relying on the Human Rights Act he
very much abused his position
as a police officer but but more
importantly he he was clearly a violent
psychopath to rewards many women and he
should have been stopped much much
earlier
the victim lived with Carrick at his
home in Hertfordshire he raped her there
many times the view from our window
the policeman shot a video inside the
house
I've regularly experienced nightmares I
have dreams where I'm imprisoned in his
house and searching for an escape
I would wake up screaming and sweating
with my heart pounding
the woman is the second Carrick victim
who's planning to sue the Met she hopes
an illegal action might help expose the
detail of the police mistakes
when she left Carrick the victim was
homeless penniless and forced to use
food banks she said the police could
have saved her from all of that
Martin brunt Sky News Scotland Yard